OUR QUESTIONS.
>> THANKS VERY MUCH, CATHERINE.
HERE WITH MORE, TWO MEMBERS OF
THE HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
CONGRESSMAN MATT GAETZ AND ANDY
BIGGS.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
>> MATT, WHAT KIND OF CIRCUS ARE
WE EXPECTING THAT WEEK?
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE HAD FROM THE
DEMOCRATS TILL NOW.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WILL HAPPEN
WHEN THIS COMMENCES?
>> THE PRINCIPLE OBLIGATION FROM
THE DEMOCRATS IS TO USE THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING AS A LAUNCHING
OFF POINT TO CONTINUE A WITCH
HUNT THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WOULD LIKE TO DO AWAY WITH.
IT'S ALMOST SIX AND TEN
AMERICANS THAT OPPOSE THE
IMPEACHMENT.
NOW THE DEMOCRATS ARE PRESENTING
IMPEACHMENT IN DRAG.
THEY'RE DRESSING UP A
NONIMPEACHMENT ENDEAVOR AND TRY
TO GET A LICENSE TO CONTINUE
THEIR ACTIVITY.
MEANWHILE, WE WANT TO SUPPORT
THE WORK THAT ATTORNEY GENERAL
BILL BARR IS DOING TO FIGURE OUT
WHY IN THE WORLD WE HAVE 22
MONTHS OF THE UNITED STATES OF
THE US BEING ACCUSED OF BEING A
RUSSIAN AGENT WITH ZERO EVIDENCE
ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHEN ROBERT
MUELLER FOUND OUT THERE WASN'T
COLLUSION AND EXPOSE THE BIAS AS
WELL.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
WHEN YOU DON'T CONTROL THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES ANYMORE.
WE HAVE A CHANCE TO CHANGE THAT.
BUT ANDY, WHAT IS INTERESTING IS
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT ACTION,
THEY WANT ANSWERS.
WE KNOW THAT THEY'RE NOT
REACTING WELL TO THIS.
IT CONTINUES DESPITE THAT.
DON'T WE WANT SOME REAL
QUESTIONS?
THIS IS WHERE THE REPUBLICANS
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO DELIVER AS
WELL, REALLY USE THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET SOME ANSWERS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WE CAN EXPECT
ON THAT END?
>> I THINK WE'RE WORKING HARD TO
PUT TOGETHER A LIST OF QUESTIONS
THAT WE THINK ARE IMPORTANT
THINGS LIKE THE ORIGINS OF THIS
INVESTIGATION AND THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL, WHAT MUELLER KNEW, WHEN
HE KNEW ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP
NOT BEING A TARGET ANYMORE, THE
INVESTIGATION.
WHY HE WAITED TILL AFTER THE
MID-TERM ELECTIONS.
TAMMY, YOU'LL SEE A DUD FROM THE
DEMOCRATS.
I'LL TELL YOU WHY.
MUELLER HAS SAID, HE'S ONLY
GOING TO RELY ON WHAT IS IN HIS
REPORT.
WE ALREADY HAVE A TAMPING DOWN
OF EXPECTATIONS --
>> YOU CAN'T -- LOOK, HE HAD
THAT WEIRD PRESS CONFERENCE.
HIM TAKING THIS CASE IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
HE TOOK IT AND IT WAS ONLY
POLITICAL FROM THE START.
ANY PERSON AGREEING TO TAKE THIS
CASE IS PART OF THE PROBLEM.
THE CHOICES HE MADE WITH WHO HE
HIRED.
I HOPE THE REPUBLICANS ARE NOT
PRECEDING WITH THE PRESUMPTION
THAT HE WILL PLAY IT TIGHT, THIS
IS A MAN WITH A AGENDA AND IT'S
TO THE REPUBLICANS TO AT LEAST
EXPOSE THAT IN THE NATURE OF HOW
THEY HANDLE THE QUESTIONING OF
MR. MUELLER.
WOULD YOU NOT AGREE, MATT?
>> I WOULD.
WE HAVE TO DO MORE THAN JUST
QUESTION ROBERT MUELLER.
WE HAVE TO EXPOSE THE BIAS
INVESTIGATION THAT WAS RUN AND
EXPOSE THE SUBSTANTIAL OMISSIONS
IN THE MUELLER REPORT.
THERE WERE FACTUAL MISTAKES.
PEOPLE THAT HAD TIES TO THE U.S.
STATE DEPARTMENT AND WESTERN
INTELLIGENCE WHO WERE IDENTIFIED
AS ONLY HAVING TIES TO RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE.
AND THERE WERE CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE RUSSIANS TRY TO UNDERMINE
OUR CONFIDENCE AND DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT BY FEEDING LIES INTO
THE STEELE DOSSIER PAID FOR BY
DEMOCRATS.
THAT IS THE REAL COLLUSION WE
HAVE TO ASK ABOUT.
>> I HEAR YOU.
I'M GOING TO ASK ANDY THIS AS
WELL.
IF YOU COULD ASK ONE QUESTION,
WHAT WOULD IT BE, MATT?
QUICKLY GIVE ME ONE QUESTION.
>> I THINK THAT WE'RE GOING TO
ASK A QUESTION ABOUT HOW HE
SELECTED HIS TEAM, THE CONFLICTS
OF INTEREST THAT HE TRIED TO VET
THROUGH.
>> ANDY, WHAT ABOUT YOU?
>> I WANT TO KNOW WHEN HE KNEW
DONALD TRUMP WASN'T THE TARGET
AND WHY THEY WAITED SO LONG TO
REVEAL IT TO THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
TO WAIT TILL AFTER THE
MID-TERMS.
>> GOOD.
THOSE ARE SUBSTANTIVE QUESTIONS.